thing you have you get 10 000 a month
not on child support no I don't I do not
I don't get two hundred thousand I don't
get ten thousand and right now we are
going through the process of child
support and custody so unless we can
work something out between us we will be
going to trial probably in a few months
right now I'm getting twenty five
hundred dollars a month okay could you
do just like 50 50 custody with him
would he want to do that
because of his career he most likely
would not be awarded because he play
he's on the road so much
um I'm very open-minded whenever he
wants to see our son and come get him
like he's getting them from the the 29th
to the 7th like because he's traveling
on this two-week period right now so
anytime he wants him I let him see him
like I mean he's I I love PJ that's why
I had a baby with him so despite like
all our [ __ ] that's been out there and
how hard it has been transitioning from
romantic to like basically strangers
that we got a co-parent now
um I still love him I love him to death
you know but um yeah so with the custody
stuff I'm very open-minded I just think
with his career it would be hard for a
judge to like award him 50 50. just
because he travels so much because in my
head like isn't it something that could
be worked out like outside of Court it
is but Hearthstone break even and
he I think in his mind he has a number
which I won't say but he has a number
that he wants to stick to and basically
when you're going through this process
for North Carolina law because it's very
different other places you don't get a
percentage if you both combine to make a
a annually over 300 000 you're
considered off the charts off off grid
so then at this point you have to prove
how much you need in child support So
any bills that my son occupies rent car
note cable groceries those are things
that my son occupies and in Charlotte
um the least amount that I could that I
could get would be 50 of each of those
expenses okay the most depending on his
career and what the judge sees fit it
could be up to 97 so whatever bills he
occupies would be covered whatever for
his clothes and diapers and all that and
then that's accumulated in a financial
affidavit is what it's called right and
then you present it to him his team if
he wants to settle outside if he's like
actually no that's too high I don't want
to do that I'd rather try my chances in
court then that's when you go to trial
do you do think that he would give you
nothing if it was up to him
for the first two months he gave me
nothing
do you think that moving forward he
would continue to
I think he would would just give me
2500.
um you don't think that's I think that's
plenty to raise a kid well when you go
based on the laws for North Carolina
it's all of the bills that my son
occupies so my car note is I think it's
two thousand
um our rent is 27.50
um for all these bills so I'm saying
it's those two bills alone are already
around but so this is just like the way
the men are gonna see this is like it's
like you're almost becoming an entitled
and I'm not trying to offend you it's
just like because to me I'm like 2500 a
month Auntie said she could do it on
like 200 a month no that's that's fine
but in in reality she doesn't have a
baby with an NBA player right so what
also is what well let me finish though
so what's why it's entitled it's law it
this isn't like my personal opinion and
I've learned actually a lot about the
law in Charlotte for child support
um my mom got a hundred dollars for me
and uh my brother but again it goes off
based on your income and what the child
would be accustomed to so that's where
all of the the opinions don't [ __ ]
matter because if my son is getting
picked up in a Lamborghini
it's like he has to be in a equivalent
like the judge doesn't want there to be
too big of a gap and that is law so
people can be upset and feel how they
want but take it up with your judicial
system like this is what it is yeah but
like the whole point is you don't have
to go to court over it now I would like
to settle it outside but that that it I
you can't if I can't let me finish
something go ahead
I have tried to settle this outside and
there's still a chance that we could
right
I have given my financial affidavit
they've subpoenaed my stuff they know
what's going all in my business they
know what's going on
it is I do not have the final say okay
so if he doesn't want to settle he does
not have to we can have a judge tell us
who should be awarded what and leave it
up to chance
like I said I wanted to settle from the
very beginning it doesn't matter what I
want because I'm asking him this is what
our bills are this is how much it would
be very reasonable number based on again
you can't lie in the financial affidavit
is it like they subpoena everything so
that's where there's full transparency
it's not like you can get a Chanel bag
with this child support this is
literally to cover your child's needs
this is not alimony people get confused
like 100 000 for a kid like that's it
depends on their lifestyle I'm saying
like this is like this is why the men
like see these laws is unfair and this
is this is why they don't see this as
Fair because I hear 2500 a month and I I
personally think and this is I grew up
in a one percent family okay like this
is I I had the life like sort of we were
like kind of like rich people that like
dressed poor you know what I mean but
but it's like like I hear 2500 a month
I'm like that's plenty for a kid and I'm
not I'm not trying to no that's fine I
don't think it's gonna like like damage
a kid if they once in a Lamborghini once
in a Honda Civic but I'm telling you
that's up to judge that's up to the
judge and that's up to law and again so
if you're if you are in it like I said
it's like greater than equal to so if
you're using a 1.6 million dollar house
a 500 000 house 400 000 house makes
sense like I'm not saying you have to be
1.6 a million like that's not what it is
so like I said people are allowed to
feel that way I would love if people
were just out of the business in general
the court system and there was something
that could be worked out but just
between families like that's it but
that's again that's a [ __ ] Ideal
World that we don't [ __ ] live in well
and and the feedback I've gotten from
men is a lot of times like we would get
more if we didn't drag their ass in
court
but like this is this is the feedback
like if you just give them time
start like a lot of times you get more
than you think you would have because
most most men want like that I know want
to take care of their kids but it's just
like when a woman because in their head
and to them it's like you're dragging me
to court you're doing all this you're
asking me for all this money and it's
like in their head they're like well
[ __ ] like [ __ ] you no well and to also
yeah
um where that point is not relevant to
me is because he served me I didn't take
this to court he wasn't paying me child
support I had to get a lawyer to figure
out what to do next but he served me
first people don't know that so I got a
paper in the letter in the mail and said
this is what we're about to do he's
taking you to court yes okay I don't
served you so that just means he serves
you yeah so it's not like so for you
saying oh well you know if you didn't
take him to court maybe he would well
he's taking me to court
so again I hear you and maybe for
majority situations that's what it is
but I was served so then I had to retain
a lawyer and like I said all I did was
got a consultation just trying to figure
out he's not paying anything in child
support what do I do and then I got
served so I had to retainer so that's
why I'm saying my situation is like I
get it it's just not uh the typical like
yeah maybe if I was just a little more
this way he would have gave me that no
he served me
I can't really I can't go I have to just
defend myself that's it
so that's where we're at like again
Hearts Don't Break Even people have
their own motives and their own
reasoning to do it as many of you know I
was just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible